good morning John so it's starting to
seem a little bit like this fun little
AI thing that we're doing is going to be
um about 30 to 40 different giant AI
things over the next three months to
five years and I'm not really ready for
that so to try and get ready here's one
thing that I've been thinking about fact
number one mongooses are native to India
and they're Weasley little carnivores
that chew up anything that's like small
enough for them to get their teeth into
fact number two when Europeans arrived
and then began to colonize Hawaii they
brought with them rats and those rats
were a problem for a bunch of reasons
but specifically this story they were a
problem for the European colonizers
sugar Plantation and so somebody got the
bright idea into their heads to bring
mongooses to Hawaii so that they would
eat the rats because mongooses eat rats
and the mongooses did not do a
particularly good job of controlling the
rat population but they did a great job
of eating a lot of native species that
had never seen a mammalian carnivore
before an introduced species that is
able to take root and change the Ecology
of an area that's an invasive species
and if you introduce another species to
try and control that invasive species
that's called biological control and
there are tons of stories of biological
control going very wrong fact number
three meta's large language model
artificial intelligence thing called
llama was leaked which means that there
is almost definitely a teenager
somewhere in Orlando Florida who has
downloaded it and is running it on their
home machine and teaching it to behave
however that teen wants it to behave and
I'm only focusing on that teenager in
Orlando right now because I would have
been that teenager in Orlando if this
had happened when I was a teenager
ecosystems are incredibly complicated
and it is very difficult to know what
effect a change will have on the rest of
the ecosystem and the only thing that I
can think of that might be more
complicated than an ecosystem is a human
society now this is a bit of a leap and
I don't love taking leaps but it might
be that a good way to imagine part of
what's about to happen is that we're
about to live in a society with a bunch
of invasive species there are no native
mammals in Hawaii except for one very
cute bat and so far in human history
there have been no counterfeit humans
that can't do all of the things that
humans can do but everything they do
looks human to us who can have goals and
work in the world in ways that we can't
predict to achieve those goals what does
a society look like when it has those
entities roving around in it and when
those entities are controlled by
everyone from that teenager in Orlando
to Vladimir Putin I don't know but I
think that we can take some lessons from
the world of ecology like there are some
ecosystems that are more fragile
ecosystems that are more isolated and
have less diversity are at greater risk
and there are some demographics and
groups in our societies that maybe have
fewer immunities built up to deal with
rapid change that is a thing to be aware
of this isn't gonna affect everybody
equally and also here's the thing now we
have gotten a lot better at things like
biological control we look very
carefully for really specific controls
on really specific Target species and
then the last 30 year 40 years there's
actually been lots of biological control
programs that you haven't heard about
because they've been successful we made
a whole Sideshow about this you should
watch it it's good and there are lots of
people in artificial intelligence right
now working very hard to say okay let's
not be that random guy in Hawaii who
ruined everything for everyone let's
think a little bit let's try and
understand what the implications of this
this can be done in better ways and in
worse ways but right now it feels like a
lot of people are just thinking hey this
is inevitable it might as well be me so
fact number four in ecology and
everything else the only thing we
definitely know is that things are going
to change but those changes don't come
linearly there are periods where there
is less change in periods of Rapid
change and it's starting to feel kind of
obvious that both for society and
ecology the next couple of decades are
gonna be kind of the Fast Times so if
nothing else
get ready for that John I'll see you on
Tuesday